[Musica]
il mio lavoro principale quello che mi
permette di di crescere i figli che
numerosi perché siamo un po' come la
famiglia Bradford Noi siamo siamo in
sette in tutto quindi siamo siamo tanti
mio vero lavoro è la pubblicitaria cioè
io in realtà lavoro cioè se voi avete
visto delle pubblicità molto brutte
Ultimamente è facile che sia colpa mia
ma devono essere molto molto brutte cioè
questa è la la caratteristica del del
mio lavoro lo faccio da quando ho 20
anni in aziende anche molto molto grandi
Io adesso ho 45 anni cioè sono la
seconda credo più giovane qui nel nel È
bello invecchiare però ve lo dico cioè
io mi sento mi sento bene perché sto
invecchiando prima c'è tutta una fase
soprattutto molto femminile di confronti
con le altre donne abbiamo parlato di
guardare gli altri no Lei è più bella ha
al naso più dritto il sedere più alto
poi c'è a un certo punto succede questa
cosa meravigliosa che si invecchia e
quindi niente Cioè L'unica cosa che ti
interessa è che ti dicano che sembri più
giovane
non vuol dire nulla sempe cioè lo capite
no Io sono del 78 Enrica sei un cesso
dell'86 grazie Quindi in realtà io
rivendico il il mio invecchiare Comunque
dicevo che lavorando in pubblicità io
una volta all'anno mi ritrovo in questo
contesto lì in situazioni di Team
building si chiamano cioè sono occasioni
in cui ci si ritrova e di solito da
questa parte del del palco c'è un life
coach
un motivatore che ti dice che deve
andare tutto bene tutto va bene tutto
non va bene tutto noi in realtà lui lui
dice delle noi in realtà così dentro
pensiamo no no no no esatt non è
esattamente così e io stamattina vorrei
ormai è talmente tanto che siamo qui che
mi sembra sembra serale una vorrei
togliermi veramente un sassolino dalla
scarpa e lanciarlo molto forte nei
confronti dei life coach dei motivatori
innanzitutto quello che non mi convince
dei live coach è il nome live coach che
vuol dire maestro di vita mi sembra in
pubblicità si dice un po' over promis no
maestro di vita esattamente il tuo
curriculum Qualè c' haai fatto
probabilmente non lo so una un istituto
tecnico esistenziale Poi se hai fatto
sicuramente l'Università della strada
con un dottorato in Giordi straordinari
un master in capodanni eccezionali c'è
già questa cosa maestro di vita per me
l'unico veramente maestro di vita Io
sono cresciuta negli anni 80 è maestro
miagi Kate Kid Ve lo ricordate Allora
Lui sì Lui sì ma lui non è che arrivava
e diceva Daniel S sono il tuo maestro No
lui umile lui il suo lavoro era factotum
n nella casa Dove abitavano Daniels e la
madre separata tra l'altro quindi tanto
amore e lui puliva i tubi faceva poi
così nel tempo libero per arrotondare
faceva un po' il maestro di vita ma
sempre con umiltà metteva la cera
toglieva la cera cioè il titolo di
Karate Kid è Karate Kid per vincere
domani non oggi domani cioè proprio
prendiamocela comoda per me quella cosa
lì è fondamentale prendiamocela molto
molto comoda Tra l'altro appunto Il per
me l'unico maestro di vita a cui do
ascolto In effetti deve essere un
immigrato di Okinawa detto questo
L'altra l'altra cosa che mi lascia
perplessa nei tra i motivatori è la
metodo Olia il metodo loro praticamente
motivano a strascico tutti uguali io
pretenderei quantomeno No un test
d'ingresso una divisione Tu sei una
motivatrice in realtà vero Sei una
motivatrice ti ho beccato No Ah no
perché non hai fatto un mezzo sorgo
detto ho pensato una merda adesso sicuro
sicuro che ho beccato quantomeno un
armoc minchiona
Scusami perdonami giustamente non
sorridi perché non faccio ridere però il
Quindi sei sei nel giusto tu la la
questione della motivazione è che in
realtà anche su Instagram li vedete ogni
tanto queste frasi motivazionali devono
andare bene per tutti che tu sia Hitler
Gandhi sei Baba o la mia estetista e la
questione è che per esempio cioè su su
Hitler Per esempio ci andrei un po'
calmo no a motivare non è che proprio ha
bisogno di di sproni anche la mia
estetista direi che deve stare molto
molto calma in Invece loro motivano un
po' strascico vi faccio un esempio di
quanto possa essere sbagliato motivare
un certo tipo di persone
prendete Giacomo
Leopardi Giacomino nostro Allora
considerate giacom pessimismo proprio è
Fastidio no pessimismo cosmico una roba
proprio Sturm Rang tremenda ok va dal
motivatore il motivatore gli dice Jack
devi devi scoprire la dimensione della
cura tu qu la vedi quella non è una
gobba è la tua specificità è quello che
ti rende unico tu stasera Tu sei
innamorato di Silia sì ecco tu stasera
vai davanti allo specchio ti ripeti che
sei che sei grande che sei unico ti fai
un bel bagno con i fiori di biscus nella
schiuma ti fai lo scrub ti bevi un
bicchiere di vino come un Alexis di
Dallas qualsiasi e a quel punto vedrai
che Silvia è tua e Silvia gliela dà e
noi Noi abbiamo perso i migliori Ma i
migliori
capolavori della poesia della
letteratura italiana di tutti i tempi
cioè capite il danno io non voglio
essere così egoista Io vorrei che
Giacomino fosse felice come tutti voi
però una cosa che dobbiamo dirci è che
il motore della creatività non solo
della creatività ma anche della Scienza
de passaggi della vita che facciamo in
avanti nascono da una gobba da una gobba
interiore o esteriore da una frattura da
qualcosa che non va bene da
un'ossessione No dal pessimismo perché
dobbiamo essere per forza ottimisti va
bene Siamo anche depressi va bene
andiamo avanti come umanità Cioè questo
lo dico
perché lei non è d'accordo però non
importa Secondo me ha fame Più che altro
come come tutti noi un'altra cosa che
non mi convince nella questione live
coach e motivatori sono le due aree Ok
ci sono come due fron i diversi di
motivazione di qua io dico Scusate dico
delle parolacce ma non sono Insomma
Perdonatemi di qua ci sono gli spacc
culis Ok spac spacca il culo cioè sono
quelli che Vai alzati ai fattura no
quelle Vai Conan non ti fermare spacca
gli ostacoli Vinci pericoli È quel
genere lì no prendi la la tua vita in
mano vai e fai spacca cisti e di qua ci
sono gli colla coccis i resilienti sono
coloro che la vita G ha un po'
frantumati sono sofferenti No sono loro
Sono tutti un po' a pezzi Così nella
nella loro resilienza e loro non
avrebbero bisogno proprio di un life
coach avrebbero bisogno di un life coach
cioè dovrebbero essere un po' un po'
rimessi insieme in questo in questo modo
loro ti raccontano sempre quella
bellissima metafora del kinsui
giapponese il kinsui giapponese lo
sapete quell'arte incredibile di
rimettere insieme i pezzi i pezzi dei
vasi rotti non li buttate via teneteli e
con una colla d'Oro No per ritornare più
preziosi di prima perché frutto di una
rottura e quindi mi hanno fatto il
kinsui scrotale con questa storia io non
li so Io butto tutto si è rotto
via Cioè basta basta e
soprattutto se ci pensate Noi prendiamo
spacc cisti incolla cisti li mettiamo a
un
tavolo mettetevi
d'accordo se voi smettete di spaccare
voi smettete di incollare viviamo tutti
più felici secondo me è molto semplice e
poi vorremo dirvi le frasi le frasi
motivazionali che io non sopporto più
queste l'anno dette anche a voi
sicuramente la prima che dicono sempre
si te stessa
Sì te
stessa quale esattamente cioè c'è questo
io dentro Non so voi io dentro ho le
Spice Girl ho tutte tutte tranne la
tettona che non ci sta ma per il resto
io ho veramente una Girl band anni 90
chi mando al colloquio oggi io il
Village People chi mando l'appuntamento
l'indiano il il poliziotto cosa cosa
facciamo Cioè già questo sì te stessa mi
manda in un totale proprio e in più per
però c'è anche da dire sempre la
questione precedente del S te stesso per
forza che qua no Siete bellissimi siete
attraenti dentro e fuori senza gobbe Ma
c'è anche la possibilità che tra noi ci
siano delle persone Brutte sporche e
cattive Ecco Loro avrebbero bisogno
sicuramente di un antipatic coach non di
una una persona che la sera prima di un
appuntamento per esempio prendesse
questa questa gente brutta sporca e
cattiva e dicesse Senti stasera devi
uscire
sì stasera ho un appuntamento Ecco cerca
di essere qualcun altro perché quello
che sei fa veramente cagare cioè la vita
nostra delle persone normali sarebbe
molto molto più bella Cioè più serena no
Saremmo Saremo tutti meglio saremmo
tutti meglio io di questo sono convinta
poi c'è l'altra frase ti hanno detto di
non splendere E tu splendi invece e
Pasolini ci piace Pasolini ci piace
Pasolini ci piace meno Pasolini messo
sulla faccia di Mafalda in un Meme di
Facebook di di un cinquantenne Questo ci
piace un po' di meno a me non piace di
questa cosa ti hanno detto di no perché
ci ci immaginiamo questa serie di speg
queste persone brutte che ti che tu sei
lì col tuo cero alla madonna te lo
spengono Cioè ma Ma quando mai Qualcuno
ti ha detto Ma no non esiste sta Mi
immagino veramente questi che sono io io
che mi metto tutte le lucine di Ikea
Cos'è quello Guarda io ti ho visto che
hai spesso hai splenduto non c'è neanche
il participio passato di splendere Cioè
nessuno ti dirà mai di non splendere
Cioè una cosa assurda Eppure noi siamo
ancora lì a dirci No noi illuminati No
abbiamo questi che ci In qualche modo ci
rovinano la vita gli Spegniti Appunto e
poi c'è la mia prefinita con cui chiudo
e questa sicuramente io sono contenta
che fin qui non sia stata detta perché
ho tremato a un certo punto ho detto
adesso la dicono adesso la dicono
attenzione io mi mi sono rovinata
l'intervento con
Esci dalla tua comfort
zone Esci dalla tua comfort zone te lo
dicono non soltanto i motivatori te lo
dicono tutti tutti te lo dicono cioè vai
dal parrucchiere Esci dalla tua comfort
zone fatti i capelli rossi ma io sembro
Il Mago Galbusera con i capelli rossi no
no no no devi fare così No Nella vai
dalla dal panettiere No non comprare la
solita baguette Esci dalla tua comfort
zone compra questo pane al carbone nero
ma il il carbone nero me lo portava la
Befana serò cattiva cioè non non voglio
io voglio il mio pane solito no come e
tutto e questa cosa dell'es dellaa tua
comfort zone mi ha sempre lasciato
perplessa Mi è stato detto veramente
tanto soprattutto nei meeting lavorativi
perché questo Cioè l'immagine che veniva
data a questa comfort zone è di un
divano un divano apparentemente comodo
tu ti siedi e le sue spire pian piano ti
portano dentro e non ti creano questa
sorta di immobilismo una roba un po' it
Tu sei lì nel tuo divano e non ti puoi
più muovere Questo è un po' Io mi
domando ma life coach Mastro viveur che
cosa ti hanno fatto sinceramente i
divani e tutta questa rottura di palle
de gli artigiani della qualità poltron
cioè il problema dove sta il problema
col vostro col vostro divano perché
siete così così negativi su sta storia
dei divani cioè io quella cosa lì non
non riesco proprio a capirla Tra l'altro
io pensavo che il conforto davvero fosse
l'obiettivo cioè un lavoro dove vai e
sei contento di andare sei a tuo agio
stai bene no è l'obiettivo una relazione
in cui ti senti proprio confortato a tuo
agio e l'obi degli amici che ti
confortano Cioè dovrebbe essere
l'obiettivo Eh ma c'è l'immobilismo Ho
capito ma siamo un popolo di ansiosi di
ansiosi E depressi ci sarà un avete
rotto le palle con questa roba della
performance a tutti i costi cioè io
voglio stare voglio stare calma è una
cosa che voglio dire qui e che io
proprio voglio non voglio non voglio
neanche soltanto una zona di confor Io
voglio una Un conforto che fa quartiere
Io voglio diventare l'artigiana della
qualità del mio conforto Io voglio
sedermi in un divano sette posti tutto
per me cioè proprio e poi non scendere
più perché the Flor is lava lo sapete No
cioè me l'hanno insegnato i miei figli
che sono anche gli unici life coach a
parte miagi a cui do do qualche volta
retta e poi soprattutto io ve lo dico
questo tenetelo a mente come per per
questo finale non ho la musica epica
però deve non ascoltate mai nessuno che
vi dica di fare della vostra vita un
capolavoro perché un secondo che si
trasforma nella merda di artista di
Manzoni
[Applauso]
grazie